We continue to add features to NCBI's genome
browser, the Genome Data Viewer.
A recent addition is the BLAST widget, which
we'll explore in the next two minutes.
You may be surprised to learn that a good
place to start your BLAST search is right
on the Genome Date Viewer home page.
Here you can choose the exact assembly version
that you want to search.
Keep in mind that this BLAST interface searches
the top-level sequences that are part of RefSeq
genome assemblies, which number well over
500 eukaryotic genomes.
Once you have your BLAST results, you will
see a link to Genome Data Viewer on the right
side of the Alignments section.
You may also see a link to MapViewer, but
we will eventually remove that.
The GDV Ideogram shows you the distribution
of BLAST hits across the genome; notice the
arrowheads.
The best alignment is represented by the darkest
arrowhead in this case on chromosome 15, which
is the alignment that I selected in the BLAST
results, and that sequence is presented in
the sequence viewer portion of the GDV.
This is where your BLAST alignments show up
in BLAST tracks.
The best part is, you now have the full functionality
of the Genome Data Viewer, including the ability
to add your own track data, and a new feature,
the BLAST Alignment Inspector, which can be
launched from within the BLAST widget.
The Inspector allows you to easily examine
BLAST alignments in a table view, or graphically,
all the way down to the sequence level.
My query in this case was a mouse cDNA, so
we see many mismatches in red.
The BLAST widget offers another way to load
BLAST results, by entering a BLAST RID number.
In the Alignment section of the widget you
can sort the alignments, and zoom to one or
more selected alignments, add a marker, and
filter by percent identity.
You can also initiate a new BLAST search from
here.
Give the Genome Data Viewer a try the next
time you run BLAST against assembled genomes.